[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGNANTI: Welcome, everyone.
Delighted to have you with us,
those here at MIT and those
at a distance.
My name is Tom Magnanti.
I'm one of the co-directors
of the System Design
and Management program.
And it's my pleasure
to welcome you
to our first
distinguished lecture
series in complex systems.
We are very fortunate
to have with us
today and over this
semester Professor Thomas
Hughes, distinguished
professor, and I
think it's probably
appropriate to say,
dean of the history of
technology in the United States
and maybe in the world.
Professor Hughes is well
known for his insightful look
at technology, particularly
look at large scale projects
and of developing a framework
for looking at these projects
and for providing
insight for all of us
at technical institutions
such as MIT and elsewhere.
We're just delighted to have
Professor Hughes with us
on this occasion.
He's going to give
two public addresses.
The first address will be
today, and the second address
will be on October 30.
And he will also be meeting
with the System Design
and Management students in
a more intimate setting.
I'd just like to,
for those who are not
familiar with the System
Design and Management program,
it's an educational
program at MIT,
whose intent is to educate
future technical leaders
in architecting, engineering,
and designing complex systems
and complex products.
The intellectual
content of this program
revolves around complexity,
complex systems,
and complex products.
There clearly are many
ways to look at complexity.
There's various modeling
approaches to looking at it.
There's engineering
ways of looking at it.
But certainly among those viable
ways of looking at technology
is a historical perspective of
trying to understand lessons
from history, what we've
learned from the evolution
of our understanding of complex
systems, our understanding
of technology.
And Professor Hughes, I
think, brings a rather unique
perspective on that in
terms of his understanding
of particular large
scale projects.
He has written many
books and many articles.
His most recent book
is Rescuing Prometheus.
It's a very notable book.
AUDIENCE: I hate to interrupt,
but the audio is very poor.
MAGNANTI: We hope
we'll improve it.
I'd like for the control room
to see if we can improve it.
His most recent book,
Rescuing Prometheus,
has gotten a great
deal of attention.
It was, I think, a
month, a month and a half
ago was reviewed in
the New York Times.
Two weeks ago, he was
on National Public
Radio to talk about this
book and got quite a rousing
responses, I understand from
my conversation with him
a few minutes ago.
He is also very much
intertwined with the system--
AUDIENCE: We can barely hear.
MAGNANTI: Let me try
another microphone then.
HUGHES: You want this?
MAGNANTI: I hope this
is a little bit better.
He's intimately involved,
has been intimately involved
with the System Design
and Management program.
I think about six
years ago or so now,
we had a committee at
MIT that was convened
by our previous dean of
engineering provost Joel Moses
and Dan Roos, our associate dean
for engineering systems, that
was looking at
large scale systems.
And we brought together,
at that time, engineers,
management people from MIT,
anthropologists, historians
to try to get our arms around
this whole issue of large scale
systems.
And I think that was a previous
occasion in which Professor
Hughes was visiting MIT.
And he joined us in
those deliberations.
So I think it's fair
to say that he's
had a touch, from the beginning,
on the overall direction
and orientation of this program
System Design and Management.
I think those of us
involved with the program
couldn't think of anyone
better to inaugurate
this distinguished lecture
series on complex systems
than Professor Hughes, who will
tell us a little bit about, I
think, some of the
elements of his book
and some of the projects
that he's been involved with
and provide us with his
own unique perspective
on these issues.
Professor Hughes.
HUGHES: Thank you, Tom.
This all right?
Coming through all right?
Very generous introduction.
I'm very happy to
be here talking
to the people about whom I
write, that is engineers.
Historians do not have this
opportunity very often.
I'm very fortunate to
have it this afternoon
and on other occasions.
Tom mentioned this
National Public Radio.
He said I got a good response.
I'm not sure it was
a good response.
I got an interesting response.
I'll tell you about it
very briefly before I
go into my prepared remarks.
The program is called
the Public Issue,
Public Concerns, Public Issue.
It comes on every
day in the week.
And after the guest
described is interviewed
about a book or
some other activity,
then the audience out
there in radio land
has an opportunity to
call in and ask questions.
And I was getting a
rather expected, what
I expected by way of
questions, until somebody
from Pennsylvania named Mike, I
believe, called in and he said,
professor, I don't want you
to think that I'm a crock.
But he said, when I was
young, aliens abducted me.
This is on National
Public Radio.
Aliens abducted me.
I spent time with them.
And I know in your
book, you write
about intercontinental ballistic
missiles and computer networks.
And I happen to know from
being with the aliens
that all of this is
reverse alien engineering.
Well, he said, did you find
any evidence to support this?
So the person who
was interviewing me
was rolling her eyes.
And all I could
think of saying was,
I've only been able to
interview earthlings.
And I said, but you
have these contacts.
And if you can renew them and
do some serious interviewing,
then turn these
over to historians,
we can use this to revise
our interpretation.
So this is true.
I mean, if he comes through
with those interviews,
we will revise our.
Interpretations.
So he seemed quite satisfied.
Today, my subject is systems,
does creating systems,
creating large complex
systems, as Tom said.
First, a word about
the historical approach
of which you will
share with me today.
I think what the historian
can do can help engineers
in several ways.
One way is to put an
engineer's present work
into some perspective.
I hope today, when I describe
the creation of several very
large systems, that you
will be, those of you who
are into system
design and management,
will be drawing
analogies on your own
with what I'm describing
historical cases with what
you experience in your
work today and yesterday
and tomorrow.
And incidentally, if you
find that my description
of these two systems, the Edison
electric light and power system
and the ARPANET system, their
creation, I should stress,
don't hesitate to
interrupt me and point out
where you think I
might have gone astray
in my interpretations of the
creation of these systems.
I'll be giving, as Tom
said, several lectures,
so I have a few
opening definitions.
These definitions I
wish to use initially
are definitions of closed
systems and open systems.
Now I've read the
biographical sketches
of a number of those
of you who are now here
in the open systems program
or in the Systems Design
Management program.
And I know some of you
are in product design,
and others of you are
in what I am talking
about today, managing projects.
But I assume that those
of you in product design,
often the activity you are
engaged in is called a project.
And so I believe what I will
say today, even though it's not
about products, say, in
the automobile industry
or products in the photographic
industry, it is about products.
Now here is a product.
I call this a closed system.
It could be called
a technical system.
In a moment, when I give you
a visual of an open system,
you will see the distinction.
Now this diagram is from a
technical journal around 1892,
I believe, something
in that period.
It's an electric light and
power systems, obviously.
What I think you might note
here is that, as early as 1982,
engineers and
managers were quite
capable of combining
heterogeneous components
into a general system.
You will notice that
some of the appliances
here are run on
very high voltage,
like the industrial motors.
Some on low voltage like
the electric lights.
Some have one frequency.
Other appliances or components
have another frequency.
But by 1895 or
thereabouts, engineers
had developed what I think you
might call gateway devices,
transformers, motor
generator sets,
and so forth that allowed
heterogeneous components
to be put on a single system.
So it is a closed system in
that it's a technical system.
But it is complex.
And now I would like
to show an open system.
Now what I hope I can
contribute to your program
and through other talks
that I shall give at MIT
is opening your minds, if
they're not already open,
to the importance
of open systems.
Open systems, as you
see from the diagram,
include organizational
components along
with technical components.
And a number of system
builders, engineers,
and managers over history,
over a long period
of time in Germany and
in the United States
and elsewhere in the
world, some of these people
have been quite good in
designing open systems
and creating open systems.
Now my impression is that
in most engineering schools,
I'm not sure about
MIT, I'm fairly sure
though, the emphasis is
not put upon open systems.
They are considered soft.
The emphasis is on the
closed technical systems.
But from my interviewing
of a number of engineers
in the large complex
systems world,
I find that a number of you,
perhaps certainly they're
compatriots, your
compatriots, your peers, whom
I have interviewed,
are in fact designing,
developing open systems.
And as a matter of
fact, they tell me
they enjoy it very much.
They are messy.
And some people consider
their work soft.
It's not eloquent and elegant
and as quantitative as closed
systems.
But it is designing these
is a challenge, which
young engineers enjoy.
I'm thinking especially
of engineers I enjoyed--
I'm sorry, yes, I enjoyed.
I interviewed on the Central
Artery and Tunnel Project.
And I would ask
them, how do you feel
about this bringing into
the design of the system,
environmental controls, taking
into account the neighborhood
politics, actually rerouting
the system because of community
concerns?
And generally, they
said it makes the design
project much more interesting.
But they added, several of
the people I interviewed,
that some of the older persons
did not find this congenial
and would not
continue the project.
Now let's take a look at
this for just a moment.
What I wish I had up
here in this diagram
was a consulting engineering
firm and also a utility.
A utility organization
should certainly be there.
And if I'd had those two and
I'd put those two into my chart,
then I could say this is
very much like the system
that the head of German
General Electric,
which was called Allgemeine
Elektricitats-Gesellschaft.
The open system that Allgemeine
Elektricitats-Gesellschaft,
AEG, created in Germany
around 1910, it was a system
presided over by a man
named Walter Rathenau, who
was an open system builder
and very good at it.
Now let me just spend
a moment on this.
The point here is
let's look at the bank.
A man like Rathenau, when
he created the system
and then later used
it, and he was trained
as a physicist and an engineer.
He was the head
of German General
Electric, which was not related
to American General Electric.
Rathenau wanted some
control over the bank.
He also wanted some control
of the consulting engineering
company.
And let's take the
bank, for example.
If his consulting engineering
and construction company, which
he owned stock in, or his
company owned stock in,
he have them stock in, if
construction activity had
fallen off, then if he had
influence over the bank,
he would urge the bank to
lower its interest rates.
And so that those considering
construction projects
would be more enticed
by the money market.
And so there was interaction,
and Rathenau saw it,
between a bank and a
construction firm in the field.
And also in this
diagram there should
be a manufacturing company.
And Rathenau, through
sitting on a number of boards
of directors, had influence
in manufacturing companies
and in utilities.
And he brought about a symbiosis
between what the utilities were
needing by way of
equipment and what
the electrical
manufacturers were producing
or would produce.
So what we have here are
functional interrelationships.
And some persons
have the vision,
as we will see in a
moment in our world
today, to put together
these various components
into an interacting system.
One thing driving these
people who do this,
and to me they're
fascinating people,
and I think, with
all due respect,
that Mr. Gates is
one of these people,
these people want control.
And they want control not
for nefarious reasons,
but they want control in
order to get the system
to function in an optimal way
so that they drive control.
Now if I can have
the next visual.
This is from The New Yorker
magazine several months ago.
And here, we have
media companies.
And you know one of the
media companies is Microsoft.
And I think most of you
are well aware of this,
but maybe I should
remind you of it,
that Microsoft is creating these
functional interrelationships.
And perhaps one of the driving
instincts of Bill Gates
is to create these
kinds of interactions
to have this type of control.
If you run down Microsoft,
just Microsoft either
through direct ownership,
through stock ownership,
or some other mode of
influence, as you will see,
is into cables, TV
and film production,
internet technology, internet
content, and so forth.
And you see these are all media
engagements, media activities.
And you can understand that
he has a mode of distribution,
say, the internet,
it's an instinct
to get control of
the content that
goes over the distribution,
over the media,
over the modes of distribution.
But if we went back to the
other diagram, German General
Electric in 1910, you
had the same phenomenon.
You had the
distribution system that
was also the
generation of content,
that is electrons, and then et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And so these are open systems.
I have another very
complex diagram here.
We can show the next one Leon.
This also is from
The New Yorker.
And the question being asked
by the person writing the essay
and doing the diagram
is, are these media
concerns, which I showed you a
moment ago, are they competing?
Are they collaborating?
And this diagram shows
companies that are owned
or companies in which
control is influenced
that connect the spiders, the
bugs across the lines drawn
between them.
And you could study that.
And you'll see a number of
companies jointly owned,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So this is a very
complex open system.
And again, the reason
it's an open system
is because organizations
are part of the system,
I repeat, and there are
technical components
in the system.
Now this is what's called
a web of collaboration.
Now a word about projects.
I would argue, and
perhaps some of my friends
here from the Sloan School
would not accept my argument,
have some in the audience who
would not accept the argument,
but it seems to me from reading
the history of engineering
management, my concern
is with the management
that has a engineering core.
And often the people I interview
and the companies I write about
are managed by persons with
engineering backgrounds.
So that's the type of
management I'm speaking of now.
It seems to me looking
back over 100 years
that projects are
becoming increasingly
the activity in which
engineers are involved.
Projects, and as I said,
projects can certainly
include product development.
Let me spend a few
more moments on this.
If one were an engineer, imagine
yourself an engineer in 1920,
and you'd accepted a job.
This is my hypothesis.
I'm happy to have it critiqued.
And you accepted a job
at the Ford Motor Company
and went to Detroit
in, say, 1925.
Still making the Model T.
I think you would
expect, as an engineer,
that you would be
asked to improve
the functioning of
the assembly lines
at River Rouge
and Highland Park.
You would also be engaged
in some improvement
in the model, Model
T. But you would
expect these changes to be
accumulative as an engineer.
I don't think you would expect
to be involved in projects that
would bring about radical
changes in the assembly line
or in the product.
And also, you would
not expect a need
to go back to MIT or
some other institution
in order to keep abreast of
the discipline in which you
were working.
That's what I believe
a 1925 engineer would
feel going to work he or she
at the Ford Motor Company,
mostly hes then, of course.
But today, one
finds that you may
become involved in a project.
And the project might bring
about a radical transformation
in product, software,
or hardware,
or a radical transformation
in the way the production
line is functioning.
And these projects remind me
in many ways of the theater.
A friend of mine who is a
director and a producer,
when I told her about these
projects and engineers
are so often
involved in she said,
oh, what you're telling
me about is open casting.
And I asked her to
elaborate upon that.
She said, all right,
we're doing a play.
We're not a repertory company.
We're doing a play.
We announce open casting.
And I know that companies like
Andersen and others do this.
An announcement is made,
such and such a project
will be put into place.
The project might engage
you for two or three months
or maybe even a year or more.
And then after you
come join this project,
and then when the project
fulfills its goal,
then we will disperse.
And you may become involved
in another project.
In the case of the
theater, open casting,
you make an announcement.
We are doing "The
Iceman Cometh."
People from all over
the Manhattan area
will come and try out for parts.
You put these people
together for a while.
They rehearse for months.
They put on a production.
And after the run is
complete, they disperse.
Incidentally, that
this open casting
when you announce that you
are going to do a play,
that's a cattle
call, incidentally.
Now they also,
repertory companies,
they do not have cattle
calls and open casting.
But they have the
same people, as you
know, doing different
projects with the same people.
And you'll find both of these
forms in the industrial world,
in the military world, and in
the university world today.
Virtual projects as you know
they're sometimes called.
And I will describe in a matter
of a few minutes, a project.
One of the classic
projects of history.
I think most of you
have heard of it.
Perhaps some of you
have read about it.
I note that people in the
Systems Design and Management,
some of you are
interested in history.
Well, this is one of the
great historical episodes.
And that is the creation by
Thomas Edison and his group
during the period from
about 1878 to 1882
of an electric
light in and system.
Now what I hope I will be able
to do in briefly describing
this project is give
you what I consider
to be the essence of
project, the project essence.
And the projects you
may be involved in
differ in detail, of course.
And projects done throughout
history differ in many ways.
But I am hoping to capture
the essence of a project
by going through this
historical episode.
First, program management, I am
contrasting program management
and project management.
I am drawing upon some NASA
policies in this regard.
NASA, in the past
at least, and many
of the things I say
come from the past,
NASA defined program
management differently
from project management.
Now first, program management in
the case of the electric light
and power system,
program management,
people involved in this
are concerned about funding
and are concerned
about politics.
And sometimes, they
must become involved
in organizational
creation as well.
Now in the case of this
particular project,
an organization had been formed.
And as I go through
this, perhaps you'll
be impressed, as I am
every time I involve myself
with the history of
this project, how
contemporary this Edison
story is in its detail.
Perhaps you will agree with me.
Perhaps not.
But a company was formed 1878
called the Edison Electric
Light Company.
Now the Edison
Electric Light Company
was formed by the
program manager types.
One of these was a man
named Grosvenor Lowrey,
who was a very prominent
New York City lawyer.
And it's not unusual
to find people
from law and other disciplines
involved with engineers
in these open system creations.
Now Grosvenor Lowrey was the
lawyer for the Western Union
Telegraph company.
So he was working in
the world of technology.
Lowrey said, I think we should
create an electric light
system.
I'll explain why he chose
that problem in a moment.
He said this to Edison.
He said, first, we must
create this company.
And this company will be an
investment and patent holding
company.
What's new?
It will fund
Edison's activities.
It will take over his patents.
It will get a return
on the investment.
This is venture capital in 1878.
And the company was formed.
Another thing Lowrey did, and
this is another requirement
of open systems, as
some of you here I know
are familiar with this,
the political stage
has to be set for the project.
And many engineers
in projects are not
aware of the
political maneuvering
that has gone on before the
project comes into being.
In this case, the councilmen
in the city of New York in 1878
were very much
under the influence
of the gas lighting people.
And so the gas lighting
people put a lot of pressure
on the councilmen in
the city of New York
when the gas lighting
people learned
that there was to be an effort
to create an electric lighting
system.
And the gas people
said to the councilmen,
don't let these people
open up the streets,
because the distribution
lines would be put underground
in New York City.
So one way to block
the project was not
to give the Edison
Electric Light Company
permission to open the streets.
Well, Grosvenor Lowrey went to
work lobbying and in other ways
in bringing about a
change in attitude
on the part of the
councilmen of New York City.
And I think you can well
imagine what he might have
done to change their minds.
So the political stage was set.
And very quickly, I don't
want to dwell on this,
but it's an anecdote.
One thing Larry did, he
invited all the councilmen out
to see a test of the Edison
electric light system in 1879.
And he was taking the--
he brought them out in
a handsome railway car,
took them around and showed
them a proto electric light
system that Edison had put up
at his Menlo Park laboratories.
And these people were
becoming very bored,
the councilmen, with
what they were seeing.
And then the councilmen were
moved into Edison's laboratory.
It was completely dark.
Suddenly, the lights came on.
The first display of indoor
lighting for these people.
And when the lights came
on, what was displayed?
A marvelous meal
from Delmonico's
with much liquid refreshment
to go along with it.
And incidentally,
that banquet had
to end within an
hour and 35 minutes
because Edison's electric
lights would not burn for longer
than an hour and 35 minutes.
Now this is program management.
We have to respect it.
It sets the stage.
Now we go into Edison
as the project manager.
Now let's forget the
heroic Edison of the books
we read when we were young.
This man was not working
alone in a garret.
He had one of the best equipped
laboratories in the United
States.
He also had his team.
His team included a physicist,
who had studied in Berlin.
It included marvelously
talented machine tool people.
There were also
chemists in his team
as well as glass
blowers who were brought
into it for this project.
I could go on and
name the craftsmen.
But the point to be made
here that the historian wants
to make, Edison had brought
this group, this team together.
And I know many of you have
been involved in teams.
Edison had brought
this team together
in earlier years to
work on the telephone
and to work on the phonograph.
Now he had this team in place,
so he had to choose a product.
He had to choose a
system that could
utilize the resources
in the personnel
that he had at his disposal.
So I think we need
to remind ourselves
that we are constrained by the
organizational concepts that
come out of the past and in
which we are working now.
We are constrained.
There are only certain
projects we'll do.
projects that are suitable.
So Edison decided
that electric lighting
was suitable for the team
that he had in place.
Now once he had
his team in place
and he had his
equipment in place,
then there was the
problem of conceptualizing
the electric light system.
And I think this is
where Edison's brilliance
along with the intelligence
of some of his team
comes into play.
And if I may have
the other diagram.
Yes.
There we are.
There's nothing in
Edison's notebooks
that gives me the
evidence to feel
confident in saying that
what I'm telling you now
is other than a hypothesis.
But from circumstantial
evidence,
this is the way that
I believe Edison
reasoned his way to his
concept, his design concept.
As you know in a
project, a design concept
comes before a
preliminary design.
Well, from this little
exercise in following
Edison's reasoning, I
think you may better
understand the man's
so-called and I
would say, yes, his genius.
You'll note the
interdisciplinary character
of the thought processes.
He realized he had to analyze
the market and with whom was he
competing.
He was competing
with gas lighting.
And from gas lighting, he
drew an analogy with regard
to the overall
architecture of the system
that he would design.
He had to be concerned about
the economics of competing,
but also this analogy
with the architecture.
It was very helpful to him.
Gas lighting or
the gas companies
were then distributing
from central plants.
They were distributing
through an entire city
from one central plant.
And Edison decided that
his architecture would
be like that architecture.
But let's go back to the
economics of the system.
He had a general concept of
what the system would be like.
He would have distribution
lines of copper.
It would have
generators, of course.
And it would have
the electric lights.
And he reasoned with the
help of some of probably
with Upton, the
man who'd studied
in Berlin under
Helmholtz, he reasoned
that the reverse salient in the
system, the bottleneck, if you
prefer, the reverse
salient in the system
was the cost of copper.
So here's a man who is into
designing an electrical system
but he realized that
materials are his problem.
And Edison didn't
hesitate to move
from one area from materials
area into the electrical area
into the chemical area.
Wherever the problem
was, he would move.
He wasn't bound by any
disciplinary restraints.
So he said, the problem
is the cost of copper,
the cost of copper in
the distribution lines.
Then he turns from materials
and cost to the science
that he had at his disposal.
Now remember this is
1878 and the science
available to electricians
is very limited.
He had Joule's Law
and he had Ohm's Law.
And from thinking
with Joule's Law
and thinking with
Ohm's Law, he knew
that the losses in
distribution would
be an equal to the square of the
current times the resistance.
Or to put it another way, the
energy loss in the conductors
would be proportional to
the current squared times
the length of the
conductor divided
by the cross sectional area.
If one increased the
cross sectional area
of the distribution
lines, then one
would reduce the energy loss
in the distribution lines.
But to increase the
cross sectional area
was to increase
the use of copper.
Therefore, this was
not an option for him
to continue to increase the
cross sectional area until he
lowered his energy
lost in distribution.
So assuming a fixed length and
keeping the cross section area
low, how was he to
solve the problem
of getting the required
amount of energy
into his electric lights?
Now he knew from Ohm's Law
that the electric lights
had to have a power
on energy consumption
which was equal to the
current times the voltage.
Now he knew from the energy
loss in the distribution lines,
he had to keep his current
low, because the energy loss
was current square.
I'm going across into
this in such detail,
it may seem
elementary, but this is
the way I think the
man's mind was working.
And so therefore, he has
to keep the current low
because current square.
He'll raise the
voltage, so he will
have sufficient current
times voltage to give him
the energy he needs
at his electric lamps.
Now how does he raise the
voltage and lower the current?
I went into an old Encyclopedia
Britannica for that period.
And I found that the way
that resistance, Ohm's Law
was stated in those days was
that the resistance equals
the ratio of voltage to current.
And there's the obvious answer.
I think that's the
eureka moment for Edison
was when he saw that by
raising the resistance
of the electric light
element, he could increase
the voltage that would be
going through his transmission
distribution lines and
reduce the current.
So that is why the man, and we
go into popular stories now,
spent months trying to
find a light filament that
gave a maximum of resistance.
And what he ended up with and
that determines even today
the standards of our
electric lighting system,
he found that he could
get a filament that
would take a current of
one amp, that it would
have a resistance of 100 ohms.
And so that would
give him 100 watts.
And so there you
have the standards
that we have in our
electric lights today
because the highest resistance
he could get was 100 ohms.
He needed one amp to get
the wattage he needed.
Why that wattage of 100 watts?
Because 100 watts gave
him the same lighting
intensity as a gas light was
giving at that particular time.
So Edison's conceptual design.
I hope that you are as impressed
by the man's thinking process
as much as I am, even though
the scientific laws are not
esoteric.
The quantitative activity
is not remarkable.
But putting together the
various aspects of the problem
is what I find
extremely impressive.
Now let's go on to
the open system.
He now has the essence of his
electric technical system,
his closed system.
Now we go into the organization
of the Edison company.
I have interviewed
a number of persons
in the field of complex systems.
And they have told me
that it's necessary
if the closed system is radical,
if the technology is radical,
it is advantageous to create
a new organization to nurture
the radical technology.
They tell me, and I'm
thinking about an interview
with Simon Ramo, who worked
on the Atlas missile,
did systems engineering
for the Atlas missile.
And I'm also thinking about
General Schriever, who presided
over the Atlas missile.
And I'm thinking about
the people who presided
over the Polaris missile.
And in both those
cases, the Polaris
and the Atlas and numerous
other system designs,
the system builders not only
produce the new technology,
but produce new
organizations in order
to get the radical
technology outside
of the bureaucratic structure.
General Schriever
told me, and I'll
talk about Atlas next
time, General Schriever
said, I had to get out,
away from those bastards
at the Pentagon.
He said, I was dealing with
people who could say, no,
and could not say, yes,
the assistant secretaries.
I had to get outside the system.
So he forms a new organization,
the Western Development
Corporation, part
of the Air Force,
but outside of the Air
Force and the Pentagon
bureaucratic structure.
Well, look what Edison did.
Edison and his advisors did
not depend upon existing
manufacturing companies.
But they formed this
consortium of companies
in which the parent Edison
company, the Edison Electric
Light Company, the venture
capital patent holding company
had interests through
stock, in most cases.
So you had the
Illuminating Company,
which is a utility, the
Edison Electric Illuminating
Company in New
York and Brooklyn,
and other illuminating
companies,
the Thomas Edison
Construction Company
to construct the electric light
and power systems, the Edison
Machine Works that manufactured
dynamos, the Edison Tube
Company, underground
distribution, lamp
works obvious.
Bergman was fixtures,
and other manufacturing
came from United Edison.
What it is worth noting here,
this system builder, Edison
and his team, they have
control of the manufacturer,
like the German General Electric
I told you a moment ago,
they're controlling
the manufacturer.
And they're controlling the
market for the manufacturer.
That is, they're
controlling the utilities
that buy the generators that
are made by the Edison machine
works.
What's new Mr. Gates?
In this effort to get control
not only of other production,
but the content and
distribution and so forth.
And so we see this control
at a very, very early day.
Incidentally, most of the
manufacturing companies
here were combined
in the early 1890s
into the General
Electric Company.
Now I want to turn
to a more recent--
well, I should say
that the system
was deployed in New York,
in Brooklyn, and elsewhere.
And the company, the
Consolidated Edison Company
flourishes in New York.
It was established by
Edison those many years ago,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
I don't think we need to go
into the further development
and deployment.
Let's now turn to
the ARPANET, which
I think you all know is the
beginning or the predecessor
of the internet.
And this story is I think one
of the remarkable accounts
of system building
in the last 30 years.
So I would spend some time
telling the story of ARPANET.
Again, I mean to
say telling a story.
Because I know most
of you are involved
in very elegant problem solving.
Your reports are rigorous
and quantitative.
And I'm telling a story,
which you usually do not
do in your professional work.
The reason I'm telling a
story is because stories can--
well, there are many reasons.
I couldn't do the kind
of work you're doing.
But another reason is stories
encompass messy complexity
in a more embracing
inclusive way
than a more scientific
elegant account can do.
So a story is one way
of conveying messiness.
And I'm arguing and I'm arguing
with some of my friends at MIT
that MIT students
need to hear more
stories of messy complexity.
They may find it soft.
And they may find it
at first not congenial.
But the people I've talked
to out in the field often
say to me, yes, yes, do tell
messy stories because the mess
is what many of
the young engineers
will soon be involved with.
All right, turning
to the ARPANET.
In following the pattern
that I have described
in the case of the
classic Edison story,
let's begin with program
management of the ARPANET.
Now the program manager
of the ARPANET, this
is my terminology, some
people in the audience
may disagree, the
program management was
the responsibility of DARPA,
the Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency.
And I trust most of you
are familiar with it.
It has been a remarkably
successful funder and nourisher
of projects since 1958.
It is still flourishing.
It has changed in character,
in policy, but it flourishes.
It has been called at times
Advanced Research Projects
Agency, ARPA.
At other times, the Defense
Advanced Research Projects
Agency.
I refer to it as DARPA.
It was founded, established
in 1958 in response
to the Sputnik.
If you don't remember,
I do remember.
You may have heard that after
the Russians launched Sputnik,
there was great
anxiety in this country
that our technology
was falling behind
and there were some measures
had to be taken the Eisenhower
administration felt in order
to respond to this problem.
And one of the
responses was DARPA,
which was to nourish and develop
and fund radical technology.
I'm using radical in
a very general way,
but highly innovative
technology, if you prefer.
Now note that DARPA
is a Pentagon agency.
DARPA gives military funding.
But I stress that because DARPA
has funded a number of projects
that in their impact and even
in the process of being created
seem rather distant
from military needs.
But let me go on with
the project management
that DARPA was engaged in
when the organization decided
to do a computer network.
All right, now first, what's
momentarily distracting me,
I see a quote I want
to give you here.
One of the major DARPA
personalities, Licklider,
said, what the military needs is
what the business main needs is
what the scientist needs.
So what the military funds
can be useful of advantage
to businessmen and scientists.
And this statement
can be made as long
as the level of
abstraction is high.
Where the businessman and the
scientist and the military
find their needs differ is
when one lowers the project
down the ladder of abstraction
to very practical, specific
applications.
But when working at a general
level, a computer network,
general, all of
these contingencies,
these clients can be
responded to at this level.
Another person I
interviewed told me
that the military is
a very big society.
The United States is
This is a DARPA person.
So is it any
surprise when we fund
a military society need we also
funding a civil society needs?
Both, for example,
need communications.
Both need calculations,
et cetera, et cetera.
All right, another
characteristic
of this program manager,
DARPA, besides its willingness
to innovate on a
rather abstract level
and respond to a
number of interest
was that the people
in the early days who
came into DARPA to manage
as program managers,
they were often on leave for two
or three years from industry,
on leave from universities
for two or three years.
So what were they bringing?
They were bringing with them a
university style or an industry
research style.
What else?
Two or three years,
and then they left.
The project was
complete for them.
Their performance was over.
They left and others came in.
It is difficult to
argue that DARPA
was a bureaucracy with hardening
of the arteries when you have
these people coming in for
short periods with new ideas
soon to be replaced by
other people with new ideas.
Another characteristic of
DARPA, the program management,
the staff was extremely
lean, relatively few people
compared to other agencies.
And another characteristic
was that DARPA
preferred to fund very
large expensive projects.
And this meant that a
small staff could manage,
instead of having to manage
1,000 little projects.
You had a small staff,
five or six people
in case of one of the
branches of DARPA,
that is IPTO, which I'll
talk about in a minute.
You have five or six people
managing millions of dollars,
but only a few projects.
Now I want to say something
about a remarkable project
manager.
I'm sorry.
I've been talking about
program management.
Now I want to talk
about a project
manager, a person who worked
within the context of DARPA.
And that is Joseph Carl
Robnett Licklider, who
is usually called Licklider.
He set a pattern of
project management
that I think has had
enormous influence
in the world of project
management and engineering
to this very day.
He had a number of
devoted followers
who admired his style,
saw him as a visionary,
and put into place and deployed
the kind of project management
style for which he became noted.
Let me say something about
Licklider in the time I have.
Note the man's pedigree.
This gives us insight into
a very interesting period
of his history and some
fascinating people.
Licklider was a
psychologist by training.
I should say here that
he was the first head
of the information
processing techniques office,
IPTO, which was that part
of DARPA, ARPA, which
presided over the creation
of the ARPANET, IPTO.
Licklider later
from 1962 to 64 was
the head of IPTO, information
processing techniques
office of DARPA.
OK.
But what I want to
stress, this man
with a background in psychology
had a remarkably rich career
that gave him to experience
from unusual capabilities.
And maybe some of you have
had similar experiences.
During World War II, and many of
the people who came to the fore
in the period about
which I'm speaking,
the '60s and the '50s, had
an interesting World War II
experiences in the realm
of science and technology.
World War II for
scientists and engineers
was a remarkable
learning experience.
Well, Licklider,
during World War II,
had been a part of a
psycho-acoustics laboratory
at Harvard University.
Then after the war,
he moves to MIT
to head an acoustics laboratory.
How does a man move from
acoustics to computers?
Well see.
Now while at MIT, he became
involved in those organizations
that were providing rich
experiences for those
who would take the risk of
becoming part of these new
and risk taking organizations.
For example, he became
a research associate
in the MIT research
laboratory of electronics.
Now that laboratory was
famous in the 1950s and '60s
for an interdisciplinary
approach.
Interdisciplinary with
something still fairly new
in the engineering world.
So he becomes a part of
MIT research laboratory
of electronics.
He also takes part
in Project Charles.
Project Charles was a
summer study project.
We don't have these
projects anymore.
Summer studies were very popular
at MIT in the '50s and '60s.
What was a summer project?
A summer project was funded
by the military, generously
funded.
The project involved inviting
a number of academics
and industrial people and
military people, maybe 30,
maybe 40, that
neighborhood number,
to just take off from
their responsibilities
for an entire summer.
Later, it became
sometimes six months.
And focus at a bucolic site,
geographical site, somewhere up
in the mountains,
down to the seashore,
these 40 or 60 people free
from their responsibilities
would concentrate upon one
particular problem of interest
to the military for
six months or a summer.
And one of the major projects
was called Project Charles,
which dedicated the
people who were members
of Project Charles
dedicated themselves
to setting up the air
defense system called SAGE.
Well, Licklider took part in
one of these summer projects.
And I'm told by people whom
I interviewed at the summer
projects, that when you
entered the door wherever
the meeting was being held,
that you were told to forget
your discipline, to forget
that you were an expert,
and that just focus
on the problem
and go wherever the problem
took you into whatever field
of engineering or
whatever field of science
because there are no experts
in this area we're exploring.
And incidentally, that
was the same technique
used at the Rand Corporation
about the same time.
Forget your expertise.
Let the problem decide where
you would do your thinking.
So Licklider was a part
of Project Charles.
Also, he heard about
Norbert Wiener.
I think all of you have
heard about Norbert Wiener.
And so he became a part of the
group that would mix and meet
with Norbert Wiener.
So this man had a rich,
rich MIT experience.
And after MIT and in electrical
engineering department
and acoustics lab, he went
to Lincoln Laboratory.
That was another great learning
experience in the '50s.
Lincoln Laboratory
was established
to do the research and
development for the SAGE air
defense project.
But it was funded
by the Air Force.
It had some of the most
advanced computers in the world.
And so if one had an opportunity
to go to Lincoln Laboratory,
as you know which is
still administered by MIT,
then one had hands on with the
most advanced technological
and specialty
computer equipment.
Then from there, he went
to Bolt Beranek and Newman,
a high technology
firm founded in 1948.
I think you're familiar
with this firm today.
It's a major player in the
acoustics and the computing
field.
So he moves on to Bolt
Beranek and Newman.
Rich experiences which prepared
him for his work at IPTO.
Now Licklider was visionary.
And what was his vision?
He had a vision
in the mid 1950s,
he had a vision of time
sharing on a computer.
And he also had the vision
of interconnecting computers.
And he often gathered together
people in the Cambridge area,
maybe over a few drinks,
to talk about the future,
the possibilities
of time sharing,
the possibilities of
computer interconnection.
He spoke a
man-computer symbiosis.
Now Licklider, in this
earlier period, the 1950s,
was not moving towards
the development
of the computer as a
calculating arithmetic device.
He was one of the pioneers.
He saw that a computer could be
used for control and decision
making and other purposes.
So the man has vision.
He has a number of followers.
And now I would like to show
you the Licklider network.
I hope you have it before
you on one of the charts.
To me, this is a
remarkable network.
Please note the movements
of these people.
These are people
with, most of whom,
Licklider is
intimately associated.
And the majority of them
have similar experiences
to which he had, MIT, electrical
engineering, Lincoln Lab.
Some of them at Bolt
Beranek and Newman.
This was the context in which
computer pioneers who made
the ARPANET learned the trade.
And note the movements of
a relatively few people
and the organizations with
which they were associated.
Now turning to the
choice of problem,
choice to work on the ARPANET.
Rather simple origin,
ARPA was funding
a number of computer
research centers
in the United States
in major universities,
such as Carnegie Mellon,
MIT, UCLA, Stanford Research
Laboratory, and so forth.
ARPA was funding these
computer research centers.
Actually, these were
computer research centers
which Licklider had
his network located.
And he funded his network
through these computer centers.
Now the cost of the
computers is very high.
And it was thought that if
one could bring these centers
to share their computers, to
interconnecting the computers,
ARPA costs would be reduced.
And according to Robert Taylor,
who was one of the IPTO heads,
the idea for this cost
saving interconnection
came to him when he was sitting
in his office in Washington.
Remember he's an IPTO head.
And he had terminals
from three time sharing
computers in his office.
I think one of the time
sharing computers was at MIT.
Another may have been somewhere
in the Washington area.
I'm not sure.
We had three terminals from
three time sharing computers.
And they were not
interconnected.
And he said, well,
the obvious thing
is to interconnect the other
time sharing computers.
And the need, of course,
is to reduce cost
by sharing computer capacity
and sharing software.
Now a word about this is the
inauguration of the project.
The conceptual
design of the project
was worked out by a
distributed committee.
In the case of Edison, who
had the people who came up
with the conceptual design,
that thought process,
that reasoning I went through,
they were located in one place.
They were in a hierarchical
structure headed by Edison.
But it is remarkable that
the conceptual design
for the ARPANET came about
through informal meetings
of the heads of these
various computer
centers, informal meetings
called by Licklider.
And Licklider, in one of the
interviews that I've used,
said, all of the heads
of the research centers
would gather at some place
for a committee meeting,
a committee of research heads.
And we'd have some alcohol
in the late evening.
And then I might bring up the
subject of computer networking.
And we'd stay up
into the late hours.
And then perhaps an idea for the
IMP, the information processor,
Wesley Roberts would
come up with that.
And then somebody might
mention packet switching,
and we would talk about that.
So what Licklider was
doing is with his network,
he was drawing out of them
the ideas through discussion
that would become the conceptual
design of the ARPANET.
Now the next step
in that procedure
was that IPTO, the office
that would preside over
this development, IPTO sent
out a call, a request for bids
to a number of companies.
And the request for bids had
this basic conceptual design
in the request.
We want a computer network
with so many nodes.
We want to use packet switching.
We also are interested in
having interface computers that
will allow their host
computers, although they
have different design,
to interconnect.
Even though they have
different characteristics,
they will interconnect
to the telephone network
through these IMPs, these
interface computers.
These ideas were coming up
through these discussions
that took place over
a number of months.
Now the fundamental
contract, the basic contract
for the design of
the IMPs was given
to Bolt Beranek and Newman,
the company which you remember
Licklider was a researcher
at and then later
a vice president of.
So this company had
the responsibility
for developing the
interface computer, the IMP.
Now I want to just say a
word as a move to conclusion
about the style
of research at BBN
because I think this
style of research at BBN
has become a rather commonplace
style in the world of projects
today.
You can tell me whether
this is true or not.
And let me read a quote from
Robert Kahn who was at BBN.
He said, BBN-- this
is from an interview.
BBN was a kind of hybrid version
of Harvard and MIT in the sense
that most of the
people there were
either faculty or former faculty
at either Harvard or MIT.
The role that MIT
plays in this episode
is a remarkably active one.
If you've ever spent any time
in either of those places,
you would know what a unique
kind of organization BBN was.
A lot of the students at those
places spent time at BBN.
It was kind of like
a super hyped up
version of the union of
the two, Harvard and MIT,
except that you
didn't have to worry
about classes and teaching.
You could just
focus on research.
It was sort of the cognac
of the research business,
very distilled.
The culture of BBN at the time
was to do interesting things
and to move on to the
next interesting things.
And there was more incentive to
come up with interesting ideas
and explore them than to try to
capitalize on them once they'd
been developed.
So BBN will develop the hardware
and some of the software
for the ARPANET.
And also one more quote
about the style and BBN.
One of the team
managers, Hart, said,
what we were doing in
developing this hardware
was a labor of love.
It was all fun.
And I have enough collaborating
evidence to accept this.
And we all on the team,
a team of 10 or 15
at BBN, we thought holistically.
We reached our
decisions by consensus.
The team leader would
only come in when
you couldn't reach a consensus.
There was no
micromanagement here.
We were suitably black boxed.
Now another interview with
one of the persons at BBN
said, when a breakthrough
occurred, we'd run in
and say, look, I
got this running.
Somebody come and type
this on the teletype.
This is exciting.
Something is cycling.
Now another characteristic of
this research that was going on
at ARPA was the meritocracy.
It wasn't a
hierarchical activity.
And one more quote.
A group of graduate students
were set up as a committee
at another site than BBN,
but this type of thing
went on with BBN too.
A group of graduate
students was set up
to develop the protocols
for the internet.
And here's a quote from one
of the graduate students.
We were just rank
amateurs and we
were expecting that some
authority would finally
come along and say, here's
how we're going to do it.
A professor would
come along and say,
here's how we're going to do it.
And nobody ever came along.
So we were sort of
tentatively feeling our way
into how we could
go about getting
this software up and running.
And there are many,
many, many examples
of this sort of
flat organization.
Now in conclusion,
I want to show you--
don't show the ARPANET.
Well, yes, quickly
the ARPANET diagrams.
These are historic.
This is the first
diagram I encountered.
It was done in longhand.
And it showed one IMP.
That's the interface
computer that
connects the host with
the telephone network.
And one host computer.
Let's see the next one.
This is by August 1972.
The other was in a few years
earlier, three years earlier.
And this is a network
as it was in 1972.
I like to show this because the
growth of the computer network
like the growth of
a railroad network.
Next one please.
And in conclusion,
something I hope
we can talk about
it at another time.
I wasn't able to give you
all of the information I'd
like to have given you
about the style of BBN,
the ARPA style of management.
I hope I indicated and
suggested it to you the style.
But out of the study
I've done, I've
come up with a contrast
between the kind of production
management that took
place, say, at Ford Motor
Company in the 1920s and the
kind of project management
that I count on
these projects today.
And let's run very quickly
through the contrast.
Before World War
II, hierarchical.
Now today, flat.
Specialization
was well regarded.
Now it's interdisciplinary.
Integration over coordination.
Rational order
was the objective.
Now messy complexity
is accepted.
Heterogeneity is accepted.
We could go on down the list.
Experts were highly regarded.
Now it's more of a meritocracy
as the anecdote I gave you
about the graduate students.
Tightly coupled to a network.
Let's have the next
one very quickly.
And then program control
against feedback control.
Systems engineering
against taylorism.
And it seems to me as
we move into the world
where projects play
an increasing role,
these are some of
the characteristics
of project management.
Thank you, Tom.
[APPLAUSE]
MAGNANTI: We have a few minutes
for questions or commentary
either from people here at
MIT or people at a distance.
Anyone like to add or ask
any questions or comment?
AUDIENCE: Professor,
I'd like to know
if there's plans to post
the slides that were shown?
Some were a bit difficult
to read from a distance.
MAGNANTI: Yes.
Yes, we do plan to
post the slides.
So they will be available
for everyone, yes.
AUDIENCE: Secondly,
I have a question
about the Thomas Edison slide
showing the organization that
was early in the presentation.
You showed that as being
separate companies,
or was that the forerunner
to Ford's concept
that was very highly
vertically integrated?
It wasn't unclear to me?
HUGHES: You're speaking
of the Edison companies?
I think you're speaking of the
Edison companies, the ones that
were established, like the
Edison Manufacturing Company
and the utilities and so forth.
These companies it
wasn't a vertical.
No, it wasn't vertical.
It was horizontal.
The companies interacted.
But there wasn't a
central management in 1882
when these companies were
established to manufacture
the generators, and the
companies established
to manufacture the light
bulbs and the underground
distribution and so forth.
No, it was a horizontal.
It was a horizontal arrangement
with the parent company,
the Edison Electric Light
Company, the patent holding
company, the investment
company having
stock interest in
these companies
and some control
through stock interests.
But it was a loosely coupled
organizational system.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MAGNANTI: Please come
down to the mic, Joann.
AUDIENCE: One of
the terms that I
was looking for in this
comparison that I didn't see
was emergent.
The project management
that you described in ARPA
seemed to me a much more,
at least in this project,
a much more emergent
kind of thing.
Because as we all
know, the ARPANET
wasn't intended to
be a communication
network originally, and of
course that emerged and so on.
The graduate
students who sort of
developed their own
standards and so on.
Could we add emergent to
this project management?
HUGHES: We certainly
could if you would define.
AUDIENCE: Emerging over
time out of the interaction
of the various socio technical
elements, but not managed,
not planned in advance.
Yeah.
HUGHES: Yes.
Yes, it certainly was,
Joann, it certainly
was a emergent project.
Because at the
beginning, as I said,
the objective was to lower
cost, the primary objective.
I haven't talked about
the military background.
The primary immediate
objective was
to lower costs through the
sharing of computer resources
and software resources.
But as you point out,
and within a few years
after that demonstration
of the ARPANET in 1972,
within a few years, email became
the major traffic generator
on the ARPANET.
And there was no
intention at the beginning
of it using it primarily
as a mode of communication.
And then also, I
think as you know,
I didn't go into this
because I assumed
you knew it, the ARPANET
after a while was turned over.
The military took over
the military aspects
of the ARPANET.
And the other parts
of it were turned over
to civilian agencies.
NSF, for example, became a major
funder of computer networks.
And so the ARPANET was
the one at the core.
But then a number
of other networks
funded by other agencies
were joined through protocol
development to the ARPANET.
So that wasn't expected either.
It's good to stress this.
And Edison didn't foresee many
of the future developments
in electric light and power.
He didn't see
alternating current.
He did not see regional electric
light and power systems.
I'm glad you made
the point, Joann.
MAGNANTI: Other
questions, comments?
AUDIENCE: Tom, I'm
trying to get a better
grasp on the difference between
an open and a closed system.
Would you characterize
the ARPANET project
as an open system
or a closed one
originally as it started out?
HUGHES: Yes.
I want to be sure this is on.
The ARPANET I call
an open system
because IPTO established
a number of these research
centers.
And the research centers were
the organizational framework
within which the technical
network was housed.
So the ARPANET involved not
only the technical aspects,
the computers, the
telephone system, et cetera,
but it also involved
the organizations,
the research centers at
the various universities.
And you couldn't have
one without the other.
So people at IPTO had to
nurture the organizations
at the same time
they were nurturing
the technical content.
And it was also an open
system because the designers
of the system had to clear
the funding through Congress.
Also, the Air Force, the
military generally was funding
and funding had to be
arranged, et cetera.
So it was a complex system that
involved technical components,
funding components,
political problems,
organizational components.
And that's the point
I am trying to stress
is most of the
technical systems you
deal with are embedded in
a larger structure that
can be called an open system.
And as Joann points out,
these open systems often
are emergent systems
and have many
of these complicated
characteristics,
extremely difficult to
manage once they're in place.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks, Tom.
HUGHES: And because of this
audience, I'll ask you.
Do you find that
projects are increasingly
common in the organizations
within which you work?
I gave you the analogy
of the theater where
a group is brought together
for a specific length of time
to solve one particular problem.
And the people on the group
may come from various parts
of the organization or company.
Then after the
project is fulfilled,
the goals are met, then the
project disbands and people go
back to their respective
areas of commitment
or wherever their home base is.
AUDIENCE: I have a question, but
my thoughts are spinning such,
I hope I can
clarify it in a way.
I'm affiliated with the
Air Force right now.
And my questions go back to the
idea of the conceptual design
and how you talked
about the network that
was among these people and the
loose style that was there.
In the research I've
been doing, I've
been seeing the Air Force
has tried to capture
these networks of people.
But they're not being
very successful.
Instead, what's happening
is those projects
that are getting funded
are from a different kind
of a person that has another
network, an informal network.
I guess what I'm trying
to say, the Air Force
has tried to formalize and
structure and establish
networks to emulate
some of these attributes
that you've talked about.
But they're failing.
And it's this
informal network is
the one that's still working.
And I'd be interested in your
comments on that and maybe
because it's something the
Air Force is struggling with.
HUGHES: I'm glad you brought
that up because it allows
me to go back to Licklider.
I think I showed this
diagram, which you have,
of the Licklider network.
And Licklider cultivated
this network informally.
But he also
structured it formally
in that he would help the people
in his network become located
in these research centers.
And then he would also, when
he had this funding resource
at IPTO, which is
part of ARPA, he
would fund people
in his network who
were located in these
various research centers.
But again, on the informal
level, again, as I said,
his people would
often gather together
at meetings he
would call and talk
into the late
hours about concept
for time sharing or concept
computer networking.
But so he was playing the
informal and the formal.
Formal being, again,
placing the people
in an organizational structure,
these research centers,
for example.
So I think the most direct
answer to your very interesting
question is in government
today, project managers,
and that's what
Licklider was, he
was a project manager for
ARPA, are extremely important.
And there are project managers
in the Air Force, as you know.
But I've been told by
some of the people whom
I've interviewed that the
project managers today are not
given the freedom and the leeway
to organize informal networks,
to draw out conceptual designs
as freely and imaginatively
as they once were able to do.
So I think the answer
to your question
is put your attention upon
the functioning of the project
managers, people like
Licklider in Air Force,
and what kind of
success are they having?
What kind of reinforcement
are they getting?
What sort of freedom
of action do they have?
And again, I repeat, I've been
told that the project managers
do not have the freedom
to maneuver and to develop
and feel imaginative
concepts that they once
had because of a number of
bureaucratic constraints
and regulations.
And I think I know what you
mean by an informal network.
That is a special
interest group that
is responding to the needs of,
say, a particular small group.
And you don't have this
drawing upon a community
that Licklider drew upon.
Yes.
MAGNANTI: Let me, on
behalf of all of us,
thank Professor Hughes for
this fascinating account of two
remarkably different projects.
I think as you explained them.
Whether one is the old fashioned
way of doing things, the Edison
way, and the ARPA is
the new fashioned way,
I think is one for all
of us to think about.
But the contrast is
rather stark, I would say,
in terms of the differences
in the organizational style
and the approach for
these two projects.
Both eminently successful
in terms of their projects.
I would recommend, again, to
everyone to Professor Hughes'
book, particularly those of
you who are interested in MIT,
because there's a lot
of MIT in this book.
I'm really impressed as you
look through it the impact
I think that MIT has had.
And all of us should
feel good about this
in terms of the way of
thinking about complex systems.
This has been an organization
that's been deeply immersed
in this for many, many years.
As I said at the outset of
this presentation today,
Professor Hughes is on
campus for the semester
as a guest of MIT.
He will be around in
the MIT community.
I think delighted
to meet with anyone
who might like to talk to
him further about these.
He will be giving another
public lecture on October 30
to pursue some of the topics
that he talked about today
and I think talk about some
other of these large scale
projects.
And he'll be meeting with
the SDM students in private.
So please join me
again in thanking
Professor Hughes for this very
illuminating presentation.
[APPLAUSE]